i'm going to just jump right in
you know welcome to the inauguration
weekend i'm going to jump right in
the um
what i'm going to do today is uh
read from notes
uh related to this topic but also do
literal readings from this topic
um
the
these are all related to
a book i literally
that's my uncle with the phone
a book
a book i literally just published jim
crow wisdom
it actually is released next tuesday
that's my only copy i have at this
moment
very well as my friend and unofficial
publicist is
has been working
aggressively to change uh the stocking
of the books i'm happy to report
actually that the books the first one is
sold out um
wish the press had published more books
but they'll be coming if you're
interested in what i have to say
uh please don't hesitate to order the
more books books will be coming soon in
any event i uh because this this book is
a mixture of traditional third person
omniscient history and first person um
narrative and i can explain why uh in
the q a perhaps if you're interested uh
it's important for me that actually read
some some of the sections because there
is
for lack of a better phrase a
performative element to the words i'm
using uh in the particular context
i want to start though i'll be reading
from or talking about reading from the
sixth and final chapter of the book but
i want to begin with the first words in
in the text uh from the the introduction
it's a poem
uh by lucille clifton
they ask me to remember
but they want me to remember their
memories
and i keep on remembering mine
i'm going to share three stories with
you today
storm number one
lunatics
this first story is about colonial
williamsburg
i went there that is me um
uh i went there in 1976 1977 and fourth
grade
uh growing up in the potomac maryland dc
area you make road trips to williamsburg
which just part of what you do and
living in that part of the country
and i had a fantastic time i did all
those things that tourists do one of
which is go into the stockade for a
great picture and then you know someone
else comes along and you move on
now in my fourth grade imagination
i didn't notice many things being an
absent-minded fourth grader i suppose
but over the course of the day visiting
the blacksmith watching how glass is
made watching how candles are made
something just struck me a little bit
off
i realized that at some point during
that day i realized i didn't see any
black people anywhere
now if you grew up in the washington dc
area to not see black people is a
strange phenomenon
but we were here we were in colonial
williamsburg i didn't really know
colonial history at the time so maybe
this is the way it was supposed to be i
didn't really know but i thought that
was you know i noticed that fact
well others noticed that fact as well
and we're bothered by this and over the
course of this is in 1976 77 over the
course of the next couple of decades
they worked very hard to change that
i'll come back to that in one second
on that same trip when i discovered or
noticed huh not many black people around
here that seems odd i think
uh i was in um
a church
uh
somewhere on the colonial williamsburg
campus
and sitting next to my mother who was a
chaperone for the trip and frankly at
this point bored out of my mind and
wanting to go home
and
leaning into her when a friend starts
nudging me in the ribs
with wide open eyes saying you know
basically saying look look look
i'm not really paying attention to the
tour guide all i hear her saying is
we know a lot we know a lot about the
history of this place
by the names that are carved on the pew
doors
that's what got his attention he looked
at the pew door
and what he noticed there got his
attention
and why i got nudged in the ribs
is that the person who owned that pew
who paid the money to support the upkeep
of the church
who was a prominent family member or he
came represented a prominent family in
that era
a person about whom we know a lot
according to the tour guide because of
the way of the promise he played in the
community his name was john holloway
these histories tell us certain things
they don't tell us other things
years would go by and i this memory
drifted out of my mind and then i
discovered
the fact that
historians knew that roughly half or
more than half of the colonial
williamsburg population was black
that was seeping out into the public
awareness at the same time curators at
colonial williamsburg are trying to
figure out how to tell
a new story
and in fact i just i didn't even catch
your name your your mother was involved
in writing the story just found out just
five minutes ago which is pretty cool
in any event
um
a new story is being told and part of
that story
eventually came to involve
um a slave auction
and in the mid 1990s the auction is
actually finally going to go off and
people are very concerned about it
there's a lot of protests from uh well
many people of all different characters
races and political persuasions
but the auction does happen
the backlash was intense
and here i'll turn to the text itself
when our emmett terrell jr journalist
and editor of the american spectator
heard about the plans for the auction he
wrote a blistering editorial that ran in
the washington times
unpack my bags
the family summer excursion to colonial
williamsburg is cancelled
the politically correct uplifters have
just brought their gruesome
hallucination of american history down
on once charming williamsburg
no longer is a is a fit place for family
outings perhaps if one's family is
composed of neurotics and hysterics
williamsburg is worth a visit but
cheerful discerning families had best
pursue more intelligent recreation
not long ago mom and dad could pack the
children into the family gas guzzler and
drive off to williamsburg for a pleasant
albeit idealized immersion into a
facsimile of america's 18th century
colonial life
standing on nearly 170 acres and nearly
100 reproductions of colonial homes and
shops
jolly women and bonnets and hoop skirts
trundled along tidy streets friendly men
in vests and cafe stockings worked the
blacksmith shop in other buildings
after an intriguing and mildly
educational day family members could
return home their imagination aglow with
visions of the american past
doubtless those of a skeptical
temperament entertained normal questions
what a disease of poverty of slavery and
the generalized harshness of the
colonial's more severe mentality
the politically correct uplifters may
find it difficult to believe
but intelligent americans visiting
williamsburg have over the years thought
about such things
yet now the heavy hoof of the uplifter
has transformed this pleasant family
tourist stop today's visiting family
returns home having been put through an
emotional ringer during which many of
the of man's meaner passions have been
dramatically displayed
skits put on by williamsburg actors
depict cruelty racial bigotry and
slavery at their worst right before
their family's eyes
terrell then sadly imagines a car ride
home in which shocked tourists
traumatized by their visit try to make
sense of this new national story
continues
all this is the baleful consequence of
new skits obtusely referred to as
enslaving virginia
one of the development managers of
williamsburg's african-american program
explains that such distressing skits as
a slave auction the harassment of
pathetic black pedestrian by slave
patrol and a discussion by slaves about
joining forces with king george's red
cross redcoats are attempts to get
tourists to confront the reality of
racial discrimination
but is a family tourist venue the
appropriate place for confronting
reality in all its grimness
frankly this is not the way i want to
spend my vacation a better place to
learn about such grim matters as slavery
is in the history is in the library with
serious book or in the theater with
serious drama
most americans rather like america which
is why as the years go on williamsburg
will attract fewer normal americans and
more lunatics
my talk today then is
about lunatics i guess
story number two
exploiting sacred ground
the sky was spotless as i made my way
through what seemed to be a gentrifying
arts district of memphis
i wasn't far from my destination but i
already was finding it difficult to
imagine a different era since it was
clear that so much had been cleaned up
in the last handful of years
even the trolley trundling pass didn't
look authentically old since it was so
clearly new
the place even verged on being
antiseptic the sidewalk seemed devoid of
any foot traffic
granted it was mid-morning weekday
mid-morning weekday in the summer it is
likely the neighborhood's character
changed in the evening when the bistros
and restaurants began to fill up for
happy hours and then again on the
weekend when the city's farmers markets
located just around the corner open for
business
i wasn't there however to go on a pub
crawl or shop for local produce
where was the museum
i should be close by
and then one block down i saw it not the
museum but the hotel
for those who study the african-american
past and likely for most people who pay
even the slightest bit of attention
during black history month or in their
high school social studies units you
could not help but notice the sign
it seemed silly to say but it looked
just like it did in the photographs
granted there wasn't a crowd of men
frozen on the balcony pointing across
the street to where james ray fired his
rifle but they didn't they didn't need
to be there to get the effect at the
moment
i literally gasped gasped and my stomach
dropped
this was the lorraine hotel
of course the museum was also the hotel
but the stagecraft of the museum was
such even the vehicles parked outside
of the hotel were vintage vehicles
similar to those in the parking lot when
king was murdered
the stage got to the museum was such
that when you pulled up to the front of
the museum the only thing you could
process with the fact that you were
staring at the hotel where king spent
his final moments the hotel from all of
the textbooks and documentaries the
hotel you knew even though you had never
before stepped foot in the hotel much
less memphis
opened in the 1920s as the windsor hotel
the building was purchased and renamed
by walter and laurie bailey in 1945. the
lorraine hotel became known for its hope
high-profile guests who were performing
a block away on beale street in the
heart of memphis black community and the
incubator of so many of the country's
blues performers
after the shock of king's murder and i
mean this literally it was a shock as
co-owner lori bailey died of a heart
attack after running out into the
parking lot and seeing king had been
shot
after the shock of king's murder the
subsequent years of urban decline and
then a post-segregated renewal that
meant that black visitors could stay in
other more modern facilities the
lorraine faced foreclosure in 1982
it had become a long-term low-income
apartment complex
where when local activists and business
leaders came together to purchase the
space at auction with the intention of
turning it into a civil rights museum
the museum opened to the public in
september 1991
before it could open
residents had to leave
jacqueline smith refused
when deputies carried her and her
belongings out to the curb after a court
order after the heat was turned off
almost a year after the original
request to leave when the deputies
carried her belongs out to the curb
she said quote dr king would have wanted
me to stay here
he said he didn't want any memorial but
he wanted to help the poor
on the morning of her eviction a sobbing
smith declared that she had no place to
go
this is wrong you people are making a
mistake
smith sat on the sidewalk among her
belongings and refused to leave
very soon construction fences went up
and they broke ground on on turning the
hotel into a museum
jaclyn smith was still there
two years later she was still there
until another court order moved her oh
deputies moved her and her belongs to
the other side of the street
when asked by a reporter
for the associated press why she was so
opposed to the museum smith reasserted
her sense that king wanted to serve the
poor and that is exactly what the
lorraine was doing when it was closed
and she was evicted
for smith the lorraine and king's legacy
were being desecrated this sacred ground
is being exploited
over 20 years have passed since this
second forced move
jacqueline smith is still there
this is a picture
taken
after 19 years and unfortunately she's
standing right sitting right here at the
fades out into the
wheel of the car so you can't see her
but she's there
with her protests
corner
when i visited that's 19 years 202 days
it was 23 years 224 days she is still
there
i was walking up to the museum planning
just to go into the museum i didn't know
this person existed i didn't know this
protest existed and i saw
something at the corner crossman hotel
and i thought it was as museums tend to
have
a
some sort of vendor selling maybe
eyes on the prize kind of material
before he went into the museum shop and
bought your stuff there so i went over
and found this protest
at 23 years
i spoke to her for a few moments feeling
very uncomfortable
not knowing what to do talking to her
and she simply said don't go in
i've flown here for only this reason to
go in this museum to study it
don't go in
this has all been gentrified this is not
look like what this place used to look
like they've turned it into disneyland
don't go in
i went in
i felt i had to go in
but as i tell the story in the book
about the lorraine hotel
most of the stories about jacqueline
smith
most of the stories about for instance
her website fulfillthedream.net that
somebody has put up for her
the website that doesn't mince words
that says the national civil rights
museum has from day one considered the
ghoulish needs of the mass tourist
market greater than the real need to
educate and inform
in one instance only the museum
acknowledges
smith's presence
on the free frequently asked questions
page faq for the museum's website you
will find the following at faq number
eight of 12. who is the protester
outside
her name is jacqueline jacqueline smith
and she has protested the museum since
ground was broken in 1987 though she has
never been inside the museum
even though the museum recognizes
smith's protest if only barely her vigil
tells us something valuable i think
about the production of history
the sanctification of certain
experiences over others and the
interplay between an individual and an
institution
here a single person with a particular
set of memories and a determination
to remember a figure of such importance
like king in a specific way
finds herself facing an institution with
a
public commitment to remembrance that
has become her
horror
and this is really what
the colonial williamsburg story is about
as well as the tension between
a public act of remembrance
for
a range of different reasons
uh when when
goodwin and rockefeller came together to
imagine colonial williamsburg
uh decades earlier they saw it as a
national shrine to the to american
ideals
when i went there in 1970 that's the way
i understood the place to be i mean i
was in fourth grade but i understood
that much that's what it was doing is
performing a certain kind of fundamental
american-ness
i like to think a little black
militantly was therefore really riled up
that there weren't any black people
there but no i just thought it was
strange
but as we know more about the past as we
learn as historians and archaeologists
learn how to read materials that were
there in front of them the whole time
that the insistence that we can't know
black history or slave history because
there's no record of it is actually a
false testimony as it turns out
this is one of the great accomplishments
of the archaeologist in colonial
williamsburg that they found there was a
tremendous record of a slave past
that changes the narrative and some
people simply don't want the narrative
changed
in the case of jacqueline smith she
didn't want the narrative changed either
and she asked fair questions
but the museum is there to do important
work as well
how do we choose
all of these are really compelling
stories i think
they raise compelling questions
story number three
a story like no other
this is a story about the southern
heritage tourism industry
since around the same era as the colony
of williamsburg's attempts to change its
narratives and successful attempts i
should say
state governments in particular have
discovered there is a lot of money to be
made
by telling stories about their path that
they never wanted to tell before
these are civil rights tours i'm talking
about specifically and as as cities like
birmingham
and greensboro and other places that
were that are financially wiped out in
the post-industrial era
they started to realize that city
fathers the way they can make money is
to build civil rights museums and
hopefully bring in tourists and they
have done this quite successfully
heritage tourism is not about a specific
building but about often
what i'll call memory trails
and
gosh and alabama
it's not in my notes here it's in the
book and the state of alabama is very
good at this they have in their state
website there are all these different
heritage tours you can go on from a wine
and cheese or wine country tour and
alabama which i didn't know existed
to the hank williams
trail to great fishing trail to civil
rights trail
coming the state of alabama that's quite
phenomenal phenomenal
louisiana though has one of the newest
ones and really one of the most robust
and in louisiana the stakes are really
quite high
petrochemicals being the biggest
industry tourism coming up really hard
uh even after the wake in the wake of
katrina has recovered this the state is
recovering
tourist economy will be the biggest
economy in louisiana and the elected
officials and bureaucrats in baton rouge
realized my god the african-american
tourist economy is massive they're
already coming to louisiana and new
orleans in particular we need to get to
take part of that and so they built the
african-american heritage trail
a story like no other and this is a
screenshot of the website
um
for a story like no other and what makes
this trail so
exciting i guess to a history geek like
me is that it's not just a website now
but it's also a smartphone app in fact a
really excellent smartphone app uh where
you you tap in you tap on the app you
can actually there's 35 different sites
within the state of louisiana you can
punch in the eight different sites you
want to go to those little stores about
each one the map will tell you literally
how to get from one to the other it's
quite beautiful it's a great way to
basically bring in tourist dollars
but
what story are people getting
on these heritage tours
when you go to that first page sorry
stop
okay good phew when you go to this page
you click on the link
um the link that you're invited to and
immediately
this comes up
a governor
like no other
a millionaire like no other
sweet
when it comes to soul food my brother
is like no other
a story
yes a story like
think of the whole setting here a back
road
probably in late winter with spanish
moss hanging off the trees
uh a romantic invocation of an idealized
sort of authentic
fundamentally natural these are all in
big quotes
black experience in louisiana
the guitar player
sings performing and blissful rapture
as a montage of images scrolls along the
right side of the screen the viewer sees
the politician pbs pinchback uh a
politician like no other met millionaire
madam cj walker before she moves up to
harlem scenes from the 1953 baton rouge
a bus boycott legendary college football
coach eddie robinson musicians playing
in a public square and soul food
matriarch leah chase in short the
introduction to a story like no other is
about celebration
and excellence and nostalgia
an invitation to explore the natural
roots of the black experience
now i actually have no problem with that
we need to get people to go on these
tours you need to find a way to sell a
feeling an aesthetic in some sense
but you have to also think carefully
about what are the the outer boundaries
of this narrative how far does this
story go
well whose memories
will matter
whose memories do they want
to remember
even if you keep remembering your own
will there be distinction between these
types of memories
the stakes are considerable there is
money on the being left on the table
if louisiana doesn't get the story right
now the office of tourism in the state
of louisiana
concerned about getting the story right
much to their credit started to gather
data on all these sizes building the
website and the app
going to all these different places of
heritage
to find out what was their story and
what they found was an incredible
breadth
you have for instance the river road
museum a very small one-person operation
uh not even on a shoe strings just on an
aglet of a budget um
and uh a museum that is doing it's doing
all this great work showing um community
gardeners of what enslaved
african americans would have planted
around their shacks as they're working
the sugar plantations on river road in
mississippi
and it's a demonstration garden
certainly but it's also literally
feeding the community
this is how
these are the stakes
in donaldsonville louisiana there's not
much there except for prisons
that the museum
which charges a suggested donation of
five dollars
can't get money from the state can't get
money from
national foundations national park
service
they're actually feeding their community
as part of the work their pedagogical
work
then you have the oak alley plantation
privately held
space as there are many of the big house
tour phenomena still privately owned
property
where the owner of the property when
approached by historians of the state
saying you know there are there are
there's a complex tapestry of stories
that can be told about this particular
site
the response was i'm not interested
oak alley visitors this is a quote for
the most part are looking for a gone
with the wind kind of fantasy
they come for the hoop skirts the
grandeur and the elegance
now get off my land now that's my part
i'm saying but but but essentially
that's what they're saying
as part of my research i went on the
louisiana african-american heritage
trail picked seven or eight sites
one of them i figured i had to do a
plantation to our big house tour
let me tell that story
i never been to a plantation before
visiting relics of a simpler era a
simpler era never appealed to me my
reluctance was predictable of course as
anyone who isn't a romantic about the
antebellum south would understand but
here i was on the evergreen plantation
not the one i just told you about the
evergreen plantation a major stop on the
louisiana african-american heritage
trail
about a dozen of us gathered for the
walking tour if i had to guess most
people were there to see the big house
i was interested in this as well but i
was mainly there to see the other
buildings
it so happens that evergreen plantation
has the largest collection of original
buildings from the air of antebellum
plantation farming over 35 buildings in
fact
the big house the gardens the pigeon air
all of these places were interesting or
lovely but more so as a collection of
still life structures or settings
the kitchen however was mesmerizing
not for the three shells of [ __ ]
memorabilia collectibles mammy salt
shakers and such that had no
relationship to the antebellum past but
were carefully displayed all the same
but for the way the tour guide explained
the daily obligations of the slaves who
fixed the meals for the residents in the
big house
the ghosts began to arrive at that
moment when the guide demonstrated how
the heavy pots would rest over the
burning wood how the cooks would use
long iron rods to manipulate those pots
how they rose every day day in and day
out to sustain those who shackled them
i was dumbfounded though when we moved
toward the slave cabins
there they were
ominously silent
down a haunted alley of oak trees
absolutely still
waiting for us
much to my surprise i was very hesitant
to go down that path
i felt i was trespassing
i was going where i did not belong
but i also meant to be confused because
these weren't my people
my people were from north carolina and
virginia
they weren't from southern louisiana
the presence of the figurative and
psychological connection however could
not be denied these were my people
history told me as much even though
history also told me that reducing a
radically diverse population into a
people was intellectually lazy
nevertheless before i walked up to the
step up the steps to the first slave
cabin i silently apologized for paying
twenty dollars
to buy a ticket to see the plantation
and to pay for the upkeep of the big
house
i apologize to all of them
henry white apolon
ben lewis joshua john edmond
tom brown manuel sterling crouch moses
fleming alfred robert
terry
george
benjamin harrison
baptiste
abraham
ambrose squire
aaron
jackson
anderson tom henry ben jean-pierre
joe
fanny chloe
duncan dunca sabelle
hector
eblini will
ersine
clara jacques
germain
alexis
and two children unnamed
all of whom were listed as property
considering the distance silence that
accompanied the displayed porcelain
grotesqueries in the kitchen
the cost per person of maintaining the
big house which was actually still
private property and occupied in the off
season
the fact that i was only that i was the
only black person on the tour and that
some of our group arrived as part of a
day-long private bus tour moving them
from one plantation to another
i found myself taking deep breaths
trying to gird myself for whatever
whitewashed narrative the tour guide
would offer about the slave cabins
the guide however surprised me
this is hallowed ground she said
we don't know enough about the people
who worked this land and who lived in
these cabins
we do know however
that they were skilled farmers
and craftsmen and that they built
everything that we have seen today
what i found to be remarkable in the
moment as it turns out was a noted shift
in the narrative a visitor to evergreen
would have heard just a few years
earlier
then visitors to evergreen would still
have seen the slave cabins but the
tourist focus would have been entirely
on the plantation house and the white
occupied spaces
the kitchen now a site where one learns
how slaves fled the fed the plantation
was then merely the place where the
owner hosted dinner parties
granted the mammy figurines remain
but one can imagine they played a more
interactive role during the dinner
parties than in their perched
gargoyle-like silence one finds today
my tour guide didn't reference them at
all
there's no doubting that visitors will
come to ever still come to evergreen
primarily to see the plantation house
and it is likely that they may see these
slave cabins as something more akin to
spectacle
than a site of violence subjugation and
loss
the tour guide's changing narrative
however
is a reflection of an evolving
sensibility about how to tell stories
about the black past
at baton rouge's
magnolia mound plantation
curators have been chipping away in a
similar fashion at older more
traditional narratives that focus their
attention on the plantation house
here i'm talking about archaeological
digs uh where there was no building
there anymore but they found shards of
glass and pottery that we now know
are actual
relics of people who might have been
healers in the slave community and we
now know more about the kind of foods
that they fix for themselves or how they
manage their lives and the magnolia
mound plantation
curator started working to restore these
slave cabins long since had burned down
or fallen down or just been just knocked
down
and they start they are now telling a
new story to the young kids who come
here ages fourth fourth grade to 12th
grade telling them a story explicitly
about who worked in the big house
and who lived in the slave cabins and
where the cabins were they have one now
on the site but they know there's a row
of about 10 in that particular place
so much of the narrative
that is written into the script for tour
guides to tell these uh elementary
school kids
is about this is a serious visit
especially especially when they get to
the slave court is this is serious stuff
no joking around no wise cracks
there's another serious thing about
magnolia mound plantation that's really
not part of the script
but it's something that curators are
trying to deal with
magnolia mound is now a 16 acre site
which used a place that used to
encompass 950 acres
in fact baton rouge and suburbs have
grown around the
magnolia mound
now the size of the of the site what
remains isn't so much a problem
but the research staff is now certain
that the private homes abutting the
property
nearest to the restored slave cabin
also happened to be built
upon slaves on marked graves
that a suburban life is perched above
unmarked slaves graves
is a silent grotesque that magnolia
mounds curators will never be able to
address unless they can start buying up
rows of currently occupied homes
something that is unlikely ever to
happen
perhaps the most
powerful side of mortal anonymity
however is found on the edge of downtown
new orleans in treme the city's sixth
ward
often returned referred to as a long
time
long time historic home
to new orleans black population there
are several stops on the heritage trail
the louisiana african-american heritage
trail within blocks of each other the
first
new orleans african-american the
first-rate new orleans african-american
museum is near to congo square and louis
armstrong park
between the two is saint augustine
church one of the oldest churches in
north america serving a largely black
and catholic congregation
the history of the church itself is
impressive
as it speaks to the unique relationship
between blacks creoles and whites in a
part of the city that has been the
economic social and cultural home to
generations of blacks
but it is a small memorial that is
outside the church
that speaks in utter silence to the
horror of loss and trauma that undergird
so much of the history that tourists
experience on the heritage trail
at first glance the memorial looks like
a small garden with a curious set of
crosses planted in it
but upon closer inspection of powerful
forces at work
there are multiple small crosses of
various size and design planted among
the tropical grasses
looming over them is a massive cross it
leans at a 45 degree angle and appears
to have been made out of a ship's anchor
chain
tangled in this cross
you can see where my mouse is right here
tangled in this cross
are half a dozen slave shackles
some intact some broken this is the tomb
of the unknown slave
dedicated in october 2004 the saint
augustine community created this site to
honor the quote memory of the nameless
faceless
turf-less africans who died in treme
more than this however the shrine was a
call to remember all slaves who lie
buried in unmarked graves
the tombs memorial plaque acknowledges
that the tomb tells a story that is as
boundless as as its subjects are
nameless
and i quote
there is no doubt that the campus of
saint augustine church sits astride the
blood sweat tears and some of the mortal
remains of unknown slaves from african
and local american indian slaves
in other words the tomb of the unknown
slave is a constant reminder that we are
walking on holy ground
thus we cannot consecrate this tomb
because it is already consecrated by
many slaves and glorious deaths bereft
of any acknowledgement dignity or
respect
as a site of historical performance the
tomb of the unknown slave is a powerful
marker of loss
absence injustice and cruelty
although based in historical fact it is
in the end a figurative assertion
a silent sentinel
over a racial horror that is boundless
and timeless
even as it also happens to be
stop number two
in a story like no other
thank you
now i stopped early with this hope that
there are questions about about this or
other parts of the project so the floor
is yours and
i'll do my best bob and weave if i have
to yes go ahead
yeah that's a great question it's about
historical reenactors
when before
the curators at williamsburg felt
comfortable going to slave auction
the first step was literally getting
enactors reenactors
to play that role of slaves and uh it
became really controversial
uh
because um
it was a race these were racially
defined roles certainly um but because
people they started to have they started
to have
problems because you can't break
character
and what they discovered much to their
heart and to the reenactors horror a
couple of things
is that
a lot of tourists who are there
simply to have a grand old time in a
beautiful setting and it is a beautiful
setting
um
strangely
started to act in a way that that i
think they might have been horrified
themselves to discover
not that they were trying to um relive
an enslaved system but the people who
were who were acting as slaves became
invisible to them
um that they were they became part of
the scenery as it were and they weren't
human actors in the way the other
reenactors were there's a strange
psychology i worked there and there were
stories of reenactors uh getting in
trouble because they couldn't take it
any longer and they broke character
to deal with people who were you know
who were cheering along when part of the
performance was of a group of people
harassing a slave as part of the
reenactment
and that visitors started getting into
it
and some of the reactions i can't i
literally can't take this any longer
and broke character and then you if you
break i don't know if you're disciplined
in some way i mean it is your job
and then they found another thing
happening is that some of the people who
were hired as overseers
to manage the slaves
they started getting into very strange
emotional and psychological space
because they these are people who were
their friends often
but the more they and they felt
uncomfortable knowing its performance
but yeah you know but they can
rationalize that as a performance but at
some moment something happened
and they started expecting
behavior out of the enacters
and so you had these white overseers
needing and i use this term
i don't know if they literally needed
counseling but basically seeking help
because they were just found themselves
in a very unsettling space as well
now
the historian me thinking about things
in a vacuum think this is a fantastic
pedagogical exercise they can learn all
about the psychological trauma of
slavery um
but you know the reality is this is
horrible
for everybody
which is the broader point of course but
if we're gonna do and this is the this
is the challenge of public history if
you're gonna tell a really complicated
story how do you do it and how do you do
it in a way that will still bring people
in because the fact is you need them to
come in not just because you want them
to learn the story but because you need
their money
especially these days when there's no
government anymore apparently um
you need their money
and this is why at the end of every i
mean this is classic museum performance
you know
right after you go through whatever
tourist
space
you're on the exit is at the gift shop
it has to be
uh and now this is getting from your
your reenactors question but you know
when i was going on these i went to um
the
international civil rights center which
is the greensboro woolworths um sit-in
site i was at um in memphis uh for at
the lorraine hotel national civil rights
museum um when you when you go through
these spaces you are not going through
feeling good
it's just like and and you know now i
study the points i can be a little maybe
a little more clinical or seeing how
they're doing but after a while you're
like
man this is
oh it's just this is horrible i don't
want to be here but i'm supposed to be
here i'm supposed to learn something
here and then you walk out into a store
where there's like you know motivational
cards and t-shirts and hats and mugs i'm
like i mean
and i actually bought some of the stuff
thinking i was going well i bought it
actually clinically thinking this is
going to be part of
the project to read
the commercial aspect of the museums
and then i also discovered that there's
this little industry in these museums
that the same
items that were for sale in greensboro
were also for sale in
memphis it just makes sense i mean there
are vendors who are who are selling
uplifting stories about survival and
such at these survival and triumph um
but it is strange to really
come to terms with these are
commercialized spaces
um trying to tell complicated stories
and those two things don't line up very
well um ever it seems and um
and the re-enactors in this case
literally uh embody that kind of
challenging
problem yes
yes danny
no i don't actually
now now say now before we get into this
danny has known i've been working on
this book for how come i don't know the
story yet
ah i see
wow
mhm
um
so your grandfather
um
that's a great story
wish i had known it in time
i mean i did know that uh he uh that he
worked before moving to the college fund
to
uh helped integrate national park
service um
sites um but i didn't know that story
any other questions that will tell me
more about the book that i wish i'd uh
put in there
good grief
yes ethan
right
um so i've actually not seen 12 years of
slave yet i did see the butler um
as research to be honest uh the
um
i think the
uh
it's an interesting tension for me
in the in the phenomenon of we need to
know
i think we need to know more and more
stories
about our nation's past
and that we really need to know
uh stories that have not yet been told
of our nation's past
those are stories of you know black
brown gay impoverished women these those
are the stories we're still trying to
figure out in many ways and we know this
what so in that way for a hollywood
movie i actually really appreciated the
kind of cultural work that the butler
is doing
um
and also for someone who grew up in the
dc area i thought it was just fun you
know just it was entertaining in the
sense to imagine
these strange worlds now but i didn't
see it for those reasons really i was
seeing trying to look for an interesting
connection um and this does speak to
where i think the butler
is doing some really important work that
i think is mostly lost in the
conversation from what i've seen of the
conversation
well it you see a bit of it i don't
think it's fully developed
and this is a story about my other
grandfather i was my maternal
grandfather's my paternal grandfather
so
the i was
after my father retired for the air
force he worked in government and then
worked as a lobbyist
for ford motor company so i grew up
going to the capitol with him just on
errands
and my father's the kind of person who
walks in an elevator and starts
conversations he knew everybody
and this is just the way he was so i
would just walk around tagging along
with my father and he'd you know see he
knew everybody they knew him
and he secured through these connections
for me one summer when i was in college
uh a really fancy internship with the
house ethics committee
and at a moment as it turns out it's
pretty important when newt gingrich
who's a backbencher started to go after
speaker right so it's actually a pretty
interesting summer on the house ethics
committee
well on the day of the beginning of the
internship he insists on taking me to
the in the the location the chambers
i'm 19 or 20 years old i'm like i can
handle this dad it's i'm fine
it turns out i couldn't have found the
place the the bowels of the capital are
endlessly you know complex but as we
walk along he's glad having everybody
you know being his lobbyist itself and
then he gets kind of quiet as we
approach what it turns out to be the
doors of of the ethics committee
and then out of the blue
right before we get to the door he goes
now hang on a second
i want to tell you something don't let
people tell you that there hasn't been
progress
i don't know where this is coming from
don't let people tell you there hasn't
been progress
because the only way you know that you
could cross this threshold we're about
to cross
when i was your age as if we were
pushing if if we were pushing carts of
food
so all of a sudden everything became
clear the reason he got this gig for me
is that he was old friends with the guy
who was chair of the committee julian
dixon late julian dixon african-american
so he goes this is a big deal you are
the chair's intern
and the subscript was uh was that the
chair is the chair is african-american
as well
and harry am walking in as a paid intern
which is a big deal back then
uh probably probably even a bigger deal
now actually um
and uh
and he just left me at that moment and
just walked away i'm like what the what
what what
and then i started to piece other things
together realizing that it wasn't he
knew the capital so well not because of
his days as a lobbyist because lobbies
just don't walk freely in the building
um not in those areas he knew it because
he grew up running around in that area
because his father was a waiter
in the house representatives dining room
but his father at every other sort of
school you have to fill out the form
about what jobs you have and whatever so
you know a typical public school form
you got to send in and my father kept
always getting in trouble because his
father would never turn in the form
would never fill out the form
and the reason he never filled out the
form because it required him to fill in
occupation
and in my grandfather's mind he was
never a waiter he was a lawyer
he had gone to howard university
in the late 1920s
at the moment he didn't know it then
when he was about to reorganize be
reorganized for accreditation
to move from a two-year night school to
a three-year curriculum that looks more
what we look like today understand today
and he was on the in the second year
when there's a credit when this change
happened and the school refused to
grandfather those second-year students
in he was about a graduate of the jd and
then started career as an attorney in
washington dc
um and yet
the school didn't grandfather this class
of maybe 8 or 12 men
and most of them
gathered together to sue the law school
for their degree
he literally could not afford a great
depression had a young kid
and so he went to work and by
connections he got a job at the house
representatives dining hall a great gig
you this is a job for life
and through that job he actually was
able to secure an appointment for my uh
for my father at west point which my
father declined which drove my
grandfather crazy
um so he had done all the work to
prepare his son and family for the
future but in his mind he was always an
attorney
not a waiter
and the damning thing is that his
friends his classmates won their case a
few years later and became attorneys
so when i see the movie the butler and
you see the kinds of internal battles
this i'm imagining going on in the
character force whitaker's character's
mind
confused in some way by this next
generation that he's raised
and their sense of privilege or lack of
appreciation for what they had to
swallow
to stand upright and do their jobs
to me that's a powerful powerful story
more than just father-son battles
whatever that i mean that's an obvious
kind of thing of course but it's really
about
um individuals
who work their tails off in positions
that uh in my paternal grandfather's
case he thought was beneath him
because his own
social
classes ability
and yet he did it
and he did it with a particular agenda
in mind
now that is a great american story about
trying to raise up a family to do the
right thing
it's not a black story although it is i
mean it's just a great american story
um
and in the case of the butler it's a
great american story told in black face
with all the kinds of slings and arrows
that come with it
so
you know for hollywood i think that's
pretty fabulous
you know for mainstream you know
hollywood um
but you know i need to see
uh 12 years a second sleep slave i need
to see fruitvale station and you see
there's a whole other industry of films
um
industry film whole other series of
films that are out now
um people are calling it a renaissance i
don't even begin that first believe that
for a second we'll see um
uh but you know if we if we can have in
our in our uh
in our cultural
political economy a less immature
conversation about race and possibility
i don't care where it comes from i think
that's pretty cool um
so i embraced the butler for that reason
yes courtesy
so i'll tell the story behind it first
lucille clifton amazing poet
um
state of maryland was asked to be the
poet laureate of maryland
african-american woman
and
she was a great honor because i'll be
happy to accept that honor and they and
it was coming up on the i think the
150th anniversary of statehood
of the settlement of maryland
colonial maryland and they're having as
one would expect a year of celebration
and um
the
so she was asked as the poet lord of
maryland if she would write a poem
to celebrate and i think and i'm
i hope i have this right um
happy colonial days
so
well
whoever asked her to write that poem
was didn't know their history very well
and they didn't know lucille clifton at
all
so she goes well okay i'll try and she
wrote many different versions and they
did not like her versions at all
um
and finally she wrote a poem
um
titled um
i've got the title right here it's mad
it's not in my notes sorry
titled
why some people be mad at me sometimes
the name of the poem
because people who gave her this task
were really pissed off at her
and this is her poem
they asked me to remember
but they want me to remember
their memories and i keep on remembering
mine
that's my whole book to be honest i mean
right there in five lines
whose memories matter
whose stories have value
which ones are loud in the pantheon of
national culture and of belonging
and really
what do what do these stories or these
memories
what do they tell us when people are so
bothered by them as well
that we can't have x in
a
statue of um
arthur ashe on richmond's
monumental way i mean
what is that telling us
about a side of remembrance
and whose stories matter and what has
value
these aren't it doesn't tell you happy
things to be honest
it's telling you grave things but it
tells you a lot about the american
character and about the work that we
have left to do
and i think i'm going to end right at
that moment thank you curtis thank you
all